you know the definition tells us that a
polynomial is a sum of monomials okay so
my normal monomial means like one term
or one group okay as some of those the
exponents are all whole numbers okay so
you're not going to have any fractions
you're not going to have any negative
numbers remember whole numbers are zero
one two three
so zero and the positive integers okay
and then the coefficients are all real
numbers so you're not gonna see any
terms that have like an eye in front of
the variable like 3i x squared that's
not going to be a polynomial and when
you write your polynomials you want to
write them in a descending order from
the highest degree all the way down to
the lowest degree so let's look at some
examples and see if you can tell whether
these are polynomials or not so take a
look at this first example here we've
got f of X equals 3x squared plus 2x
plus 1 so what do you think is that a
polynomial well it's looking pretty good
you've got a sum okay of monomials it
doesn't have to be all added you know it
could be adding a negative when you're
subtracting this just like adding a
negative but it looks like the
coefficients okay the numbers in front
of the variables these are all real
numbers you don't see Nia eyes okay for
example for imaginary and when you look
at the exponents these are all whole
numbers they're zero or the positive
integers so yes this is actually a
polynomial so this one will working
right yes okay the second one here we've
got f of x equals 3 times the square
root of x plus 2 x squared minus 7 what
do you think is that one a polynomial
well this one actually is not because
when you look at this square root of x
square root of x is really going to be X
to the one-half power and you can see
that exponent is not a whole number
right it's not zero and then the
positive integers this is a fraction so
this one is not a polynomial we're gonna
write no for that one okay the third one
here we've got f of X equals square root
of 5x cubed plus 4x what do you think is
that one a polynomial well at first you
might look at the square root in front
of the accident think oh that's not a
whole number but that's okay you can
have irrational coefficients just as
long as your exponents okay of your
variables are whole numbers and this
isn't imaginary you don't see an eye
there so this is actually okay this one
is a polynomial so we're going to write
yes for this one
okay now this one here we've got f of X
equals five over X
- eight what do you think is that a
polynomial well when you see that X in
the denominator so you could really
rewrite this as 5x to the negative one
because the negative exponent takes the
reciprocal or moves that variable to the
denominator and you can see negative 1
is not a whole number so you can see
that this is actually not going to be
considered a polynomial so we're gonna
write no for that one this one here
we've got f of X equals two-thirds X
minus 7 you've got a fractional
coefficient that's okay you just don't
want a fractional exponent so this one
is if a polynomial so we're going to
write yes for that one and then the last
one here we've got f of X equals 4x to
the negative 2 plus 2x minus 1 what do
you think is that a polynomial well
we've got a negative exponent so again
the exponents have to be whole numbers 0
or positive integers so this one is not
a polynomial so we're gonna write no so
I hope this helped you to understand how
to determine whether a function is a
polynomial or not
subscribe to the channel check out more
math videos on my youtube channel
Mario's math tutoring and I look forward
to helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon